now as promised my exclusive interview
with White House chief of staff
General John Kelly we began with the
indictments announced in the Special
Counsel Robert Muller's Russia probe
today general Kelley thanks for being
with us let's start with the news today
these indictments were handed down Paul
mana Ford of course his associate mr.
gates and another minor aide to the
Trump administration George papadopolis
what's the administration's reaction I
saw a tweet early this morning but
what's the reaction well I would offer
to you first of all Laura my job is such
that I am completely consumed between
zero six hundred the morning and
whenever I get home at night which is
usually pretty late I'm not in a
position to watch very much in the TV I
know that the gentlemen were indicted
today all of the activities as I
understand it that they were indicted
for was long before they ever met Donald
Trump or had any association with the
campaign but I think the reaction of the
administration is let the legal justice
system work everyone's innocent til
resumed innocent and we'll see where it
goes with being chief of staff as you
are now three months in is this a
difficult moment for the staff or staff
worried when indictments start being
handed down that this is just the first
second third shoe to drop but there'll
be many more to follow no I think the
staff is very comfortable with simply
serve in the nation the vast majority of
the staff would have nothing to do with
any of this kind of thing yeah so
there's no there's no worry about it
everyone is just doing the things that
they were hired to do to serve the
nation I think the president made it has
made it clear what he thinks about the
uranium one story and the fusion GPS
story but what do you think do you think
there should be a special council
appointed to investigate all of these
narratives coming out with a DNC in the
Clinton campaign actually funding
research that was in part compiled by
the Kremlin Kremlin associates well I'm
one of those people that think the
American people I really do have a right
to know what their government does have
a right to know what their government is
doing on any given day and by the same
token what private citizens are doing if
they break the law again everyone's
presumed innocent
but I think with it with the the focus
of that's been on mr. Trump and the
focus that's been on this Russian
collusion which of course is not the
case at all with mr. Trump we were very
very confident that these kind of
accusations you know unfortunately the
u.s. population outside of the echo
chamber that it's Washington essentially
could care less about Washington DC if
you go out there into the henna lands
people don't care they discussed it you
know if you look at the at the the rates
of acceptance among the US population
the US Congress the media is all way
down and they single digits are in the
teens most people in America look at
Washington with amusement but not with a
lot an awful lot of respect or interest
so I think it's doubling important than
when these kind of accusations are made
that they should be investigated there
any sense that Bob Miller who was
heading the FBI at a time when this was
being approved the uranium one and that
he should recuse himself from any such
investigation of this I think miss
kamala right now it's pretty busy doing
what he's doing I think this whole
another I guess so I mean again not a
lawyer one of the strengths I have in
looking at issues in my job I think
probably is as a layman looking at this
kind of thing we need to find someone
who's very very objective who can get to
the bottom of these accusations I think
it's important again the American people
have an absolute right to know these
things unless things were classified
this administration certainly you saw
mr. Trump do this the other day when he
demanded that to JFK documents be
released in their entirety was very very
very few redactions but nothing held
back and that's where he is on this and
certainly that's where I am with mother
said it should wrap up soon I mean it
would seem that there towards the end of
the of the witness pile and I don't know
how much longer it could possibly go on
but we're in great hopes that it wraps
up it is very distracting to the
president as it would be to any citizen
to be investigated for something while
at the same time trying to carry the
weight of
being president outed States means
ownership time does this take up for him
well you know he and I have as you might
imagine multiple conversations a day
generally in in the morning when we
first talk
it'll be about these kind of things just
general conversation before we get down
to business but it is very distracting
for me you have a big trip to Asia
coming up this week we heard about the
previous administration I'm supposed to
pivot to Asia from Asia we never really
saw it what's the administration's goal
on this trip well just to I mean he
first of all he has great relationships
with the the leadership in South Korea
Japan and China and then of course a
commitment to that region of the world
to be involved so he's going to build on
those relationships and of course we'll
do two conferences one in Vietnam and
one and we'll go to Hanoi to touch base
with the national leadership there and
then go to them to the Philippines where
he'll meet for conferences but where
he'll meet the the President of the
Philippines all of this is just to
solidify relationships that are already
pretty positive in my view Japan wants a
nuclear language from the United States
if North Korea should launch an attack
on Japan they want to feel like there
will be a strike by the United States
are you guys gonna give them that
language that they want the this
commitments in place for us to help pay
the overwhelming force is not
necessarily saying a nuclear response
that's exactly right but what we really
hope what I should say what the
president really hopes and we all all
men and we'll feel this way is that the
leadership such as it is in North Korea
come to their senses with the help of
countries like China decide to
denuclearize give up their atomic
weapons there's no reason for them
there's certain no purpose for that
country just destabilizes a number of
relationships and obviously an ICBM
programs is FC no reason but I don't
think I don't think we can have a
country like North Korea have a ICBM
that can deliver a nuclear now
a thermonuclear device on the mainland
of the United States they already have
the capability to at least reach with
missiles to the great American citizens
that live in Guam congressman Trent
Franks talked about the possibility of
North Korea with its hydrogen bomb
capabilities ultimately being able to
explode an EMP over the middle of the
country now electromagnetic pulse bomb
yeah and you play that out that could
ultimately lead to the death of like 90%
of the country cars don't work computers
don't work nothing works without the
computer any longer what about that I
mean that that's a scenario that's Newt
Gingrich sort of novel about that but
it's it's that is the kind of thing that
I think about keeping you up at night
because when I started reading about
that that really is terrifying and
that's why he cannot have a ICBM that
can deliver a survivable nuclear device
to the homeland but there come in close
law and I just you said this was the
issue that kept you up at night more
than any other issue is it still it
really still is because it's such a
destabilizing but it was a great the
great hope we all have and they're
already doing this is that the Chinese
exert their pressure they were already
observing the sanctions we know that to
exert pressure on the leadership in in
North Korea we have great hopes for the
Russians as well
President Xi was just re-elected he's
being compared now to Chairman Mao he's
of that stature in China the president
tweeted out a comment basically
congratulating President Xi on this
historic victory I'm paraphrasing but my
hope killed like 60 million people like
it's a communist country why are we kind
of celebrating Gee's presidency is
because we need them we need their help
we'll move in the North Korea problem
again as Americans we wouldn't we can't
conceive of accepting a government like
that such as it is but that is not us to
pass judgment on I think working with
people and that who they
it's better than not talking to them
they have a system of government that is
apparently works for the Chinese people
and but but let's let's hope that let's
hope that this is a new kind of leader
and not look back so many decades that's
our relationship with China they fed
friend foe trading partner well you know
they've beat us pretty badly in terms of
trade that doesn't make them an enemy
they are to say the least a world power
that doesn't make them an enemy
they're probably in many ways have been
smarter than we are in terms of business
and in the trade President Trump has
committed to change in that relationship
on a on a collegial basis the the
disparity between what we buy and sell
from them is very great but by no means
are they I wouldn't even consider them
competitors necessarily just simply
another world problem 60 billion dollar
trade I think it's closer to five but
that's whose fault is that I mean that's
all felt yeah well they're doing why
hats off to them for taking advantage of
whatever they've been able to take
advantage of to have that raid
relationship this president has
committed to change in that relationship
but to do it in a in a you know
collegial way we have an acting
assistant secretary for Central and
South Asian affairs at state we still do
not have a permanent assistant secretary
in other words it's a career diplomat no
offense to Alicia Wells but it's not
trumps pick why is that Wow why is a
snail's pace of getting people will
nominated and approved the the names
have been put forward in many in most
cases I think where and the president
was making this case last week when he
had lunch with the Republican caucus on
that on the Senate side we are if you
compare where this administration is
relative to the Obama administration we
are way way behind maybe less maybe half
the number of
those confirmed and even under the last
Bush administration we're way behind you
know the the Senate Democratic
leadership has been very very effective
in slowing things down to its snail's
pace as a Secretary of State slowed
things down at State Department has I
mean the reports are that there's a bit
of a divide there that some of the names
that the president wanted have been
rejected and that means then we don't
have these key positions yeah I mean I
would tell you that there's an awful lot
of incredible vetting that goes on so
when you're not before you nominate it
to take a position or even before the
president considers you and because
before the secretary considers you
there's a there's a tremendous amount of
vetting that goes on and frankly a lot
of people have complicated finances and
have complicated lives those positions
are gonna be filled they will definitely
be filled at one point you were reported
to say that on the refugee question
you'd like make between zero and one
refugees coming into the country now the
president said forty five thousand
refugees traditionally it's been about
twenty thousand a year
overwhelmingly from the Middle East
their Islamic very few Christians still
coming in what's happening there and why
that number is so large given what you
advocated and what the Trump President
Trump campaign I don't ever remember I
read that action my wife told me who
your wife did she's always right by the
way I don't ever remember saying between
zero and one my my my time at DHS was
definitely we should not take refugees
into the country unless we know who they
are and in consequently we've improved
the the vetting process the vetting
process to date although it's lengthy
two years the vast majority of it is a
two-year way to come to the country the
point is that we're down from 110 45,000
one of the things that always does
astound me about the refugee question is
is about 65 million people who are well
I think by UN numbers but a large number
anyways that are technically refugees
and only a tiny fraction of that can be
brought to the United States so to
Western Europe a diverse area it just
seems to me and most people I think that
are
they think about the refugee issue it's
theoretically a temporary problem best
thing to do is to house them as close to
their countries as possible and to to
solve the help solve the problems inside
the country like we have say in Syria
you're satisfied of 45,000 I think it is
extreme betting but I don't know where
this zero to one ever came okay and how
we extreme that it what's what is
extreme vetting the same vetting is we
simply interview people and have to
satisfy ourselves that the person we're
talking to is indeed the person who have
to do in some cases there are no records
it possible to do in some cases so they
won't come in that you can't really
verify that if we can't verify I don't
think we should let them into the
country